get 25% off a subscription to Babel by
clicking the link below
Babel helps make our show possible and
it's an app I actually use myself to
improve my Italian and it's definitely
the first language learning app I'd
recommend to anyone
go check it out this next story is sort
of a cross between sad hilarious but
also disturbingly emblematic of the
absolute absurdity not just of this
administration but of the last seven
days in Trump land eeeh our fearless
orange leader in the middle of an
impeachment inquiry going formal of
being booed and shouted lock him up at
during a World Series game and his
staged post Isis raid photo-op has been
reduced to tweeting pictures of dogs to
put it lightly with inaccurate claims
about the dog take a look at this quote
we have Declassified a picture of the
wonderful dog named name not
Declassified that did such a great job
in capturing and killing the leader of
Isis Abu Bakr al-baghdadi so first of
all is there anything more cringe-worthy
than continuing to tout in the most
bizarre way possible this raid over the
weekend as if it was Donald Trump's
doing but then maybe more importantly
the dog did a good job capturing and
killing al Baghdady al Baghdadi died by
suicide at his own doing using a suicide
vest that he was wearing killing three
of his own children in so doing what on
earth is going on here and there's
actually a lot of sort of weird dog
related imagery literal and metaphorical
Donald Trump not only tweeting pictures
of dogs related to the al-baghdadi raid
but remember that Donald Trump used the
word dog multiple times during his big
speech announcing the death of al
Baghdady to denigrate people calling
them dogs when I saw this tweet what
maybe struck me most viscerally was that
there's a realization I had I guess that
Donald Trump could never have a dog
because he just doesn't really care
about other beings in the way you have
to to properly care for a dog and this
really is just a lead-up to the
her story of all the lies that Donald
Trump has been telling about the death
of Abu Bakr al Baghdadi which I'm gonna
get into next but let me remind you when
I think this bears repeating
earlier this week I showed you a tweet I
believe it was on Monday where Donald
Trump back in 2012 said listen why are
we criticizing rather why are we
praising Barack Obama so much for the
killing of Osama bin Laden
it was our servicemembers who did it
let's stop praising Barack Obama because
Barack Obama didn't do it that same
tweet basically tells you everything you
need to know about what is going on this
week and the much the same way that when
the bar letter was released in advance
of the Moller reports several months ago
Donald Trump used the bar letter to
justify a national exoneration and
vindication tour which of us which of
course was completely an absolutely
bogus but it worked
Donald Trump is similarly using this
raid against al Baghdady
to justify his own existence essentially
and to Pat himself on the back in ways
that are completely beyond what the
facts dictate now in the next segment
I'm going to get to what level of credit
does Donald Trump deserve for this but
first let's review the lies that Donald
Trump has been telling